this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
is offering our listeners their first
three meals free
that's three free meals when it comes to
dinner let blue apron take care of the
planning and shopping while you do the
cooking and the eating you'll enjoy
delicious meals like popcorn chicken
with sweet chili cabbage slaw and cumin
spiced wonton noodles with vegetables
and peanuts on the table in 30 minutes
are left or less it's really great I
love it I haven't had a bad meal yet and
I don't plan to and I don't think that
they're going to let that happen so
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free a blue apron calm
/ Congrats blue apron a better way to
cook this episode is also brought to you
by the cash app the babies are no
stranger to the cash app we all use it
it's probably why it's the number one
finance app in the App Store and now the
cash card is more powerful than ever
with cash apps latest feature cash boost
download the cash app get your free cash
card and select your boost save money
when you swipe on stuff like coffee
Chipotle Shake Shack and more download
the free cash app or for iOS or Android
now we're also on episode 70 of
congratulations the podcast and this Rob
just keeps getting crazier and crazier
doesn't it
dead knit but we're here for you let me
go through some of the dates here I got
coming up Ottawa Ontario Buffalo New
York Burlington Vermont Philadelphia
Washington DC New York New York
Montclair New Jersey Portland Oregon
Snoqualmie Washington Vancouver I just
added another show Miami West Palm Beach
Jacksonville Atlanta Los Angeles
San Francisco Toronto Boston Fresno
Bakersfield Austin San Antonio
Wilmington Delaware Tulsa Midwest City
Oklahoma
Dallas coming up Portland Maine Hampton
Beach Mashantucket Connecticut change it
Houston
Wichita Kansas City Missouri
Lincoln Reno Las Vegas well I'm gonna
Lincoln huh I didn't know that well I
forget because my agents like why don't
we do this and I say K and then it's I
forget and then I think then somebody
says hey you ever been to [__]
Wichita and I go and I say nah why the
[__] would I ever be there and then I
look on my website and I'm going cuz I
forget um anyway I want to start this
there so that's the follow-the-leader
tour people are saying come to Utah you
know on my app na was there last year he
missed it it also takes a little bit for
you know trying to develop new material
so if I was there already in like you
know August I'm not gonna be back for a
little bit because I'm still doing this
material to follow the leader' tour and
I'm trying to get a cracking all across
in America all across the America but
you know you babies are tried and true
man and your your coming out every time
I go out and I do another city there are
more and more babies there and this is
the time to push it further than ever to
get these people part of the cult to get
these people to be in with us if not
turn around if not could come because
the door to the log cabin closes you
know there's multiple entries how about
when the guy was like when the guy was
like the problem with the school
shootings is that there are too many
doors there are too many entry and exits
hey hey when was the last time an
entrance killed someone hey remember the
horror movies and the [__] thrillers
where the good guy is like [__] this I
got a right this wrong and then he grabs
an entrance and goes and [__] rights
wrongs oh no oh no he grabs guns
remember when the bad guy in the movie
tries to rob banks with an exit Hey
oh no he uses guns you got to be a
special kind of [__] to think to say
something like that and then it went
away the next day went away the next day
because everyone forgets about
everything cuz everybody's complaining
about everything and then what happens
is you complain about a new thing and
everyone forgets about the last thing
yeah nobody gives a [__] in there a hero
with their phone yeah
hey nobody really gives a [__] and there
a hero sitting behind their computer yay
[Applause]
I mean I just liked this post on Twitter
that my buddy posted about somebody was
like trying to do some kind of quote
unquote article about one of the guys in
the bachelor on The Bachelorette what's
warmed was the one with the guys vying
for the [__] the Bachelorette bachelor I
don't [__] know [__] piece of [__]
trash a show
stupid [__] dumb show bachelor
Bachelorette [__] dumbass show you
know and if you watch it ironically [__]
you you're worse
you're worse dude no I just watch it
because it's funny
you're worse no you're cute cuz you
watch it cuz you have batch because
you're a guy and you have Bachelorette
or bachelor [__] viewing parties oh
you're cute cuz of that get a
personality get a [__] personality you
know anyway yeah he somebody wrote
Garrett what's the tweet from HuffPost
oh they're great
Garrett you rego Yin change it first of
all one of the 28 cast members on Becca
who friends season of The Bachelorette
appears to have a history of liking
social media posts that mock trans
people undocumented immigrants left-wing
women and one Parkland High School
student and then my buddy Chris Paul
writes hopefully we can destroy him
nothing I love more than saving the
whole entire world from my computer
phone when I get bored enough to open an
app that is an Instagram that's like a
perfect response it's like first of all
that's not an article dude you know how
much I don't I'm looking I don't know
the guy I don't know what he liked maybe
he likes something that's it maybe he
likes something completely racist or
whatever and that would obviously be
[__] weird and not cool but like I've
liked some dumb [__] on Instagram like
just dumb [__] you know
this [__] stupid [__]
we're like if my kids would see it I
don't have kids but when I have them and
they see my Instagram later they'll be
like that how come here like this why
did you like this the guy's face came
off he's bleeding everywhere
III don't know I guess I just kind of
but like to make an article first of all
never write an article about anybody
that's ever been on The Bachelorette
okay no don't write articles about some
[__] [__] that's hoping for a
rose ah say yet that's so lame I you
know I always think like Oh whose fault
is it the person writing the article or
the person who reads it are the people
that eat that [__] up it's the person
who does its fault I've come to that
conclusion like the stupid [__]
Instagram videos that are like
quote-unquote funny but not on the
wavelength as we know they they it's
their fault for doing the stupid [__]
don't do the stupid [__] video yeah
people are also dumb for following you
but don't do the video period it stops
there what came first the chicken or egg
the check so uh so yes so the guy said
no entrances or I mean I don't know it's
so [__] weird the the [__] that's
going on in this country that now here's
the thing to the football [__] where
they were like oh
football players made it you know not oh
they can't kneel otherwise they get
fined and people are like that's not
right you can't do that that's
anti-american and then the same people
that now are dragging Roseanne and
saying the same people that did that are
now saying fire Roseanne fire Roseanne
it's it's quite literally the same thing
it's quite literally the same thing you
are what you hate you're just on the
other side of it and I'm not condoning
what what anyone did if that's racist
and shitty what you know what Roseann
did it actually just happened I even
really read too much about it but like
what she did was idiotic and stupid you
know but let's not pretend like
canceling that show isn't going to have
the worst [__] backlash it's going to
be awful for the left now I'm a guy who
identifies with the left but also I'm
more embarrassed than ever that I do
that cuz crimes
now what's a crime it's short for
cry-baby there was a video I saw today
on Vice that was that was look my bottom
line is you got to pick you got to make
the rules for yourself to live by the
reason why the matrix is such a good
movie and this is why I always say this
is because it creates a crazy world and
it adheres to the world to the rules
that are in that are that are involved i
watch this [__] show on this show
safe with michael c hall it was a soap
opera none of it made sense
the characters were all doing things
that they didn't that they weren't they
weren't they weren't they made this
world and then all the characters broke
the rules makes in a sense that's what
we're doing you're saying or it's saying
it's not American to [__] find these
uh football players with and then of a
fire this person for saying that well
which is it dude which is it I was
looking at this this vise I mean it's a
larger issue than this [__] podcast
here it's a larger issue than me saying
what I'm saying I am I don't I don't
know you know I barely know what I'm
talking about but you got to pick a way
to be you know and they're private
companies I get I get that you can't
work for Disney and then also call a
black person from Planet of the Apes or
what are the [__] rosetta did it like
that's what Rosanna did was [__]
stupid and they reserve the right to
fire her
but there's like it's a nuance thing why
do I was get rid of that pillow when I
need that pillow it's a nuance thing
this whole dragging you know
quote-unquote culture is just annoying
as [__] like where we dragged the [__]
out of somebody I was look what it
becomes you know I was looking at this
video on Vice that was talking about
this I tweeted it but it was like a vice
video that was talking about colleges
like Emerson and some other college that
nobody's ever [__] heard of that that
they're talking about how they couldn't
they there and I've done this dude I'm a
comedian and I've had colleges be like
oh they want we want you to do this show
but you can't talk about religion I say
no I say no if I could tell my agents to
write in a response go [__] yourself I
would but they won't do that because
they're mages and they always go like I
mean I've told him to do [__] like that
and they're like well you know we can't
do it because you know I keep the
relationship no [__] that relationship
dude if you're hiring me to do stand-up
the thing that I've worked on for 12
[__] years then you get what I got
dude I don't show up and then adhere to
your rules I go if I tell you to turn
round and I grab a handful II the back
of your hair and whoopsie I slipped
inside yeah you got royally [__] why
college campuses can be minefields for
some comedians and and you know what
dude I take these gigs and I and I and I
and I and I I say there's no rules no no
restrictions right my agents say none I
go there and I tell these [__]
college kids I do the jokes and these
college kids listen and sometimes look
the college kids don't know what they
believe yet so everything is almost
offensive because they haven't figured
themselves out yet and that's fine too
when I was their age I didn't know
myself either I didn't know myself till
yesterday okay but when you're a
stand-up comedian and you're up there
and you're coming to my show
you're not gonna get [__] offended
and if you do you're getting I'm
visually [__] you that's it your dude
that's it you don't get to be offended
these are jokes period when I feel oh
dude I had a Stephen Hawking joke and he
died and I was like well I'm still gonna
do the joke just cuz he died I'm still
gonna do the joke now when I do the joke
anyone oh oh [__] you dude shut up
it's a joke so I was watching this thing
on Vice on Vice and it was talking about
Emerson was one of the colleges and to
other colleges that nobody ever [__]
heard of and they were like oh you know
we don't want them to be you know
colleges are more diverse than ever so
they can't make transphobic jokes they
can't make jokes about rape they can't
make jokes about sexual assault if
they're more diverse than ever then why
are they all thinking the same goddamn
thing ah you mean they're not diverse
cuz you mean they're more diverse
because they're different colors kiss my
[__] ass they're all thinking the
same thing hello we're welcome hello one
ticket for the comedy show yeah hello we
have a group of four with the [__]
light red light across the mouth you
know you know hello four tickets to a
comedy show how are we are programmed to
laugh at the things that are not
offensive yeah we all agree because we
are all on the same network commence
sitting commence laughter mode welcome
comedian hey guys what's going on ha ha
ha so the pink n' isn't just for girls
ha ha a guy can wear pink too yah yah
yah yah yah
meh I agree I was programmed to agree we
are all program Tory laughs in unison
yeah III III III III ah what a beautiful
comedy show well well hello guys I'm the
comedian for tonight you can be you can
be a man or a woman whether you can
having sex look this is how much I don't
know about it
sex isn't gender haha that's like saying
peanut butter is jelly oh my god this is
the most hilarious comedian I've ever
heard in my life yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
must tweet about how great he is anyone
who opposes will be dragged thanks for
coming out everyone
whoo we had a great time here at the
most liberal ascribe a bee is [__]
College of all time it's called cry-baby
you well I am so happy to get my diploma
at a crybaby you I am so happy to be
here everyone please welcome the
valedictorian of snowflake of state of
state snowflake state university hello
hello students
now you will embark on to the real world
yeah yeah iiiii yeah yeah yeah yes we
will let you know that the real world
can be tough out there some people think
that you don't think don't really care
what you think oh wow that really can
take the sail out of your out of your
the wind out of your sails auto-correct
wind out of your sails but it's okay the
real world those people will be in jail
because you cannot speak out against
what is liberal otherwise
people will go to jail and we basically
live in the 12th century now yes name is
that problem is that the one name its
net everyone receiving their diplomas
Scot is the same note the same noise
that when when you watch the [__]
horns and the and the girls are getting
are getting tight you ever see the porn
where they're like on the gynecology
[__] chair and the [__] big robot
arm [__] him and it's like Scott who's
watching that huh only really fat guys
and really skinny guys watch that you
can't have a regular body and watch that
[__] you have to be like really frail
and you're like oh or you're like with
the watch the more get [__] by robot
arms and there's just so fat and you eat
the food on your belly it's big as a
rubber dildo and then it goes faster
it's like it goes it's like like turn it
off e why are you in a dungeon always
cuz it's wrong hey if you're in a
dungeon what you're doing is wrong the
lower you get the worse you are if
you're on the [__] also if you're CEO
of a company you're probably evil too
and you're on the top floor and get
somewhere in the middle how about
everyone remains on the ground that's
that's it that's when you're [__]
morally okay needs me it's gay thank you
so much I am prepared for life now yeah
do it just so [__] like I don't know I
don't understand why liberals don't
don't get that what they're doing
is only going to make it worse for them
and what they believe pretty soon
they're gonna be on the end of of
because it's like it's like everybody is
offended nobody's offended and
everything is funny until it's offensive
to you you know what I mean and that's
[Music]
hello students I would like to prepare
you to the for the real world if you are
black and somebody says something
negative about you or if you are white
and when somebody says something
negative about you or if you are a Asian
and somebody says something negative
about you they will be fired and dragged
across the social calls of injustice
[Music]
also you can be fired for breathing
wrongs you can remember America is a
place where you can say whatever you
want until it doesn't jive with the
community America so many hydraulics
[Laughter]
whether you're American you may say
whatever it is you please unless it
doesn't jailer the community or also
doesn't speak to a fringe group
[Music]
[Applause]
you are now prepared to embark on the
real world and remember hook up to our
system so you know how to feel if you're
unsure of how to feel please sign in to
the Wi-Fi snowflake and the and the
password is cry-baby remember we all
think the same and if we don't you will
be executed now now it is time for the
after graduation party here we go it's
time for the graduation party
god damn [__] yes here we go wait a
minute was there to the N world that was
the N word must find digit Caledon pump
him and then [__] him and kill him I
don't even know what I'm talking about
anymore I mean you know I'm so hood you
know I'm so hood a man hands it across
my neck and it's a man said I mix my
neck that bit I did it way too long but
whatever dude that's what you get that's
like my dad do it my dad will [__]
take a bit and run it into the ground
that's why I get it I'll be like he also
does the same joke you do only like
makes it one word different and then
like laughs again and then my brother
and I always every time someone does it
we go oh said dad my parents made me
[__] move a rug again goddamn it dude
every time I go over there all they do
hey I need you my dad will text me and
my brother we got to get to it we got to
have you here earlier today we got maybe
prepared to stay later we need extra
hands mom has a couch she wants you to
move mama has a rug she wants you to put
down you know I go I write sigh right
fine and then we get there she wanted us
to put the [__] rug on of course
it's always like the hardest [__] you
can't just be putting a rug down on a
room it has to be like I want it to go
under the bed and then there's a trunk
and I want you to leave the trunk there
and then make sure it's even and then do
it without bending over and you're like
what this is a [__] physical
challenge and then we did it and it took
like [__] an hour and then she wanted
us there was like a rug [__] man I'm
some there was like a rug to put an edge
already there and she was like I don't
want you to take it out I want you to
just put the rug over the rug and I was
like all right and my dad was like no
you got to remove the rug and I was like
dad you're making us do more work just
[__] let us put the rug down that's
what she wants and he's like okay and
then we did we put the rug down and this
rug under it was bigger than the rug
that we put over it so it was like
[__] peeking out and [__] and then
the rug was not was all lumpy and [__]
and it wasn't like and my mom I was like
wise is lumpy she's like I don't know I
never seen a rug like this and then she
was like it's an outdoor indoor rug and
my brother was like was it used already
was it is it was a wet it's all warped
and so she was like just leave it and
now she's got a [__] shitty ass rug
on top of another rug under the [__] and
it's not the way she wanted and my back
hurts but my dad was like my dad was
like why don't we why don't we just hire
somebody and this and that and we'll get
somebody to do it professionally did it
all in front of me and my brother making
us feel like a Sur [__] anyway I
posted a video on Instagram about it and
I went there got so many likes and [__]
it's weird how people love to see your
family it's so weird to me I don't give
a [__] about that [__] like you're
seeing Chris Pratt's family I don't give
a [__] I just want to see Chris back and
running around with guns and [__]
fighting aliens that's all I give a [__]
about maybe I want to see a work out of
his or something that's it I don't need
to see all of his family [__] the second
you do that though that's what it should
that's when the people really feel like
they're a part of your life meaning
um I don't know man I don't know what
all I know is there was a guy in Spain
or something that got like arrested and
put in jail because he spoke out I had a
concert against the president it's like
that's where we're headed dude that is
quite literally where we're headed if we
keep this up some Brazilian comedian got
sued I was talking about this on I did
the your mom's house podcast that's
coming out in a few weeks but Segura was
telling me that this comedian got sued
like a hundred thousand dollars and lost
all of his endorsement still cuz he made
a terrible joke I'm like a whatever the
good morning out a good morning [__]
show is in Brazil and it was a bad joke
but he tried to make a joke that's it
man you get the comedian and he made a
joke about how like something like Oh
somebody with some woman was pregnant
he's like she's so beautiful I would
have sex with her and her baby which is
bad but like he should be like whoops I
[__] up that was stupid and that's it
that's it he was trying to joke but
they're suing him and he lost like a
hundred thousand dollars lost all of his
endorsement deals like it's like what a
it's like what Judy gold said on the on
Vice on that vice interview it's like
she said the world you know stop trying
to make the world change to you or
whatever she said I'm paraphrasing it
but like you the world is the world and
deal with it like that's he [__] up
everyone feels so good about themselves
when they're behind their phone or a
keyboard and they drag the [__] out of
somebody like they never said anything
wrong and we all said I say this on the
podcast I said a time a time again
people aren't what they say they're who
they are now you keep saying the same
thing over and over again it's a general
pretty good indication of who you are
but if you [__] up once or twice
[__] it man [__] it um anyway okay here
we go the truth is most of us are
brushing our teeth wrong
not for long enough and forget to change
our brush on time that's because most
brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks
rather than better brushing like most
companies but you know what not quip so
what makes quip so different well quip
is an electric toothbrush that is a
fraction of the cost of bulkier brushes
while still packing the just the right
amount of vibrations to help clean your
teeth quipus built-in timer helps you
clean for the dentist recommended two
minutes with guiding pulses that remind
you when to switch sides I follow it it
comes with the amount with a mount that
suction is right your mirror you don't
lose it I'm an idiot I'll lose my
toothbrush I really will even though it
should just be right there but it's cool
because you could put it on the on the
mirror and it on sticks to use as a
cover for a hygienic travel wherever you
take your teeth which is everywhere
because your teeth are in your head it
was on Oprah's olace name one at times
best inventions and the first
subscription electric toothbrush
accepted by him the American Dental
Association and they're not wrong about
teeth quip starts at just $25 and if you
go to get quick comm / Congrats right
now you'll get your first refill pack
for you with a clip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get clip com / Congrats spell GE t q UI
p comm / congrats blue apron delivers
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
step-by-step recipes right to your door
that can be cooked in under 45 minutes
the menu changes every week based on
what is in season and is designed by
blue aprons in-house culinary team blue
apron offers 12 new recipes each week
and customers can pick two three or four
recipes based on what best fits their
schedule blue apron sends only non GMO
ingredients and meat with no added
hormones
I like blue apron because it's the right
amount of food you know you're not
overeating or under eating
and you feel good after you eat it and
I'm being dead serious it's always been
good even stuff that I didn't know I
liked they've introduced me and made my
palette more sophisticated and that's
the truth even though I hate to admit it
because I hate to admit to about me
changing but they're good I need to do
more stuff like this in my life but blue
aprons helpin upcoming meals included
pork chorizo tacos salmon and spicy
orange salsa white cheddar cheese
burgers creamy pesto cavatelli so check
out this week's menu and get your first
three meals free at blue apron comm /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
if you haven't heard we're all switching
to the cash app now that's all the
babies if you haven't and you're a baby
you're not a true baby by now you know
it's the number one ranked app in
finance and lets you do the most with
your money whether you want a paperback
buy and sell Bitcoin deposit your
paycheck right into the app or order a
free custom cash card to spend anywhere
you like and now the cash card is more
powerful than ever with cash absolutists
feature cash boost the cash cards boost
program lets you get instant discounts
every time you swipe your card right now
you can get $1 off every purchase you
make it coffee shops across the country
when you pay with your cash card to get
boosted download the cash app get your
free cash card and select your boost a
cash card black debit card is another
thing that we did here at
congratulations get the card and you can
design your you can put a design on
there show your artistic side and it's
very cool show us your designs on
Twitter or Instagram when you do it buy
and sell Bitcoin crazy cool crazy hip
and you're the future if you do that so
of course when you download the cash app
and you enter reward codes Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five dollar
goes to time's up Legal Defense Fund
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now yeah I
I don't know thinking about the comedian
[__] and and all that like how it's
crazy that everything's changing and
comedians are now like being censored
and [__] like that which is awful I mean
for me it's one of the worst things
because I'm a comedian but also it's
weird to me to think that the Liberals
are the ones that want this growing up I
always thought like of it as like a
super far-right like conservative thing
like oh you can't say this you can't say
that like conservatives are like oh we
don't talk about those things because
they're not proper you know what I mean
[__] like that but it's like completely
the opposite which is weird it's about
it's like we don't talk about that
NACA's it's not proper because it hurts
our feelings which is like buck up adult
I mean kind of just say the same thing
over and over again here but yeah I just
was I don't know I had a point here what
was it being a comedian and and all that
I just feel like it's weird like III
I've been thinking about why I do comedy
why'd you stand up and it's genuinely
because I make people laugh and
generally because I like to make people
laugh and I like to make myself laugh
you know I used to say stand up I do
stand up not because I don't do stand up
to make other people laugh I do it to
make myself not cry and like that's a
joke you know but it's it's a little bit
it's a little bit true because it makes
me so happy and it you know because I'm
so happy it I'm sad less and all that
but you know I know comedians talk about
everyone a good notion for that
comedians or artists do this to fill a
void or whatever it is that they're
doing in life it's to fill some void and
that [__] is nonsense
man I can't stand that whether you have
a [__] sex addiction or whatever the
[__] it is some people just do [__] cuz
that's what they're doing they're
addicted to it or they like it or they
have fun doing it this void that
everyone's talking about is so stupid
man people who talk about a void since I
was born man all I hear oh we do this to
[__] fill the void I ain't just
trying to fill the void oh it doesn't
help buying all those clothes it doesn't
fill the void what void is everybody
[__] talking about man
I just like the color yellow so I bought
the goddamn sweatshirt it doesn't have
anything to do with a [__] void dude
I don't do stand-up to fill some void
I don't do it cuz I you know if there's
some secret meaning or this this this
this thing in my psyche that's like ah
[__] but this is why games got man back
I'm just doing it because it's fun and I
like it there's no trauma there's no
this there's no that there's no the
other thing
I'm just doing it cuz I like to get on
stage like a baseball player likes to
swing the [__] bat that's it that's
it I'm gonna try to hit a home run every
[__] time because that's what's fun
and that's what feels good but there's
no void there was this thing that was
it's like you know there's this thing
about I was I was reading on Twitter the
other day and i retweeted somebody who
said something about this people think
because you that you got a struggle to
be [__] artistic and good now look
dude first of all if you like my art at
all that goes that [__] goes in the in
that flies in your face I had a great
childhood I love my family I love my
parents I was happy as [__] yeah I'm a
[__] weirdo and I definitely have an
anxiety disorder and OCD but you know
what is that what you mean by the
struggles certainly not there's people
out there literally getting [__] and
tortured you know so so it's like you
know this and then this guy would in
this course this guy made it about race
which was like annoying to me he was
like he started off by saying like
there's this thing there you thought
were there's this thing that people
there's this notion that people think
I'm paraphrasing but that people think
that you need to go that you need to
struggle to become a writer and this and
that
that's not true and I was like ah he's
right and he's like I hear a lot of
white guys saying like aw they wish they
had struggle and this and then they made
about a made about race and it was
annoying as [__] to me and I was like ah
this guy [__] baited me into this
tweet that I thought was gonna be good
and then he was like all white people do
this all you know is like Jesus Christ
dude I mean man I'm [__] getting
tired of everyone saying how [__]
dudes suck and how white dudes suck I
mean I get it but do it come on there's
a lot of people out there they don't all
do the same [__] thing man you just
go go on Twitter and just type in [__]
men suck men are horrible look how many
[__] tweets come up you know and and
for if anybody said that about any other
kind of group it'd be it'd be it your
career will be over your career would be
over
if [__] anybody see that's why you got
to do all the [__] you got to get that
you got to get the fans you've got to
lose the fans up front you have to lose
them up front so you get the genuine
people that are going to follow you this
is what this cult is about I come out
and I'm telling you how the [__] it is
up front there's no secret agenda
there's no although this is how it's
gonna be I'm telling you all the
thoughts up front because that's what I
believe is right and look at this I'm
just the first thing this is hard all
men are garbage cuz some some guy all
men are garbage first with a comb so
[__] all men [__] all men with these
signs
Scorpios can't leo stupid this is
[__] all men Morgan Freeman accused of
sexual harassment by eight women and
then this person [__] all men I mean
what huh how about when Morgan Freeman
when that [__] idiot on was it CNN
was like he looked at me and said I wish
I was there and he and Morgan Freeman
and then it showed the clip and Morgan
Freeman was literally talking about if
you see the whole clip did you see this
Michael Caine was like one time I told
Michael Caine was like one time I told a
girl I made a mistake and I asked her
when her pregnancy was due and she
wasn't pregnant
and then Morgan Freeman says I wish I
was there and the person conducting the
interview thought Morgan Freeman meant
because he was looking at her that he
wish he was [__] her yeah what a joke
dude what a joke you're [__] up you
are [__] up everybody's actual pain
you are not letting the people who get
who have been hurt heal because of your
trivial [__] that's completely wrong
and this woman would be the first to say
I'm a survivor for what dude you didn't
jump into a volcano
you weren't brutally raped at knifepoint
Morgan Freeman said something about
Michael Caine's story and you think
you're a [__] survivor all men are
[__] here's another one all men are [__]
boys all men are terrible oh wow
one fire just wrote all men are I'm
gonna just I'm
to tweet some today men are beautiful
how many reach I get 76 retweets I have
a [__] 700,000
it's weird dude and they and those
people want it's like you know those
people want equality and you know I get
the white man has been on top for you
know years and years and years and years
but you gotta be careful man it's we've
talked about it before but there's this
there's this tendency to let the
pendulum swing the the too hard the
other way and it's almost impossible man
I mean dude I'm sure if I was in the
minority and I was getting [__] on for
you know years and years and years my
whole life I mean how could you not have
some hatred towards [__] white guys
it's a tricky [__] thing man it's a
tricky [__] thing it really is it's
so hard to be the better person it's
actually [__] so hard man it's it's
like almost impossible I mean I'm a
[__] I've been I've been the worst
man a lot I seek out tweets so I can be
the worst man and [__] respond you
know III I search my name not my handle
I search my name on Twitter cuz I want
people to I want to see negative things
about me cuz then I want to get to
slamming I'm petty and people are like
are you that insecure
it has nothing I'm not saying I'm not
insecure but this has nothing to do with
being insecure I'm a slammer it's fun
for me
it's batting practice I do this for a
living I like to do it oh I'm just if
some guy was like [__] you I'm sticking
up for my friend that's exactly what I
was doing stick it up for me this is the
this is the world this is earth it's not
gonna change for you you know as if you
know taken off of what Judy gold was
saying okay forget her [__] name which
is stupid
she's funny I was looking up some of her
stuff um anyway I don't know what else I
what else dude here let's get look let's
not be so heavy let's talk about
something a little bit less right now
just because it's been on my mind
sometimes this [__] sticks in my mind
and it bothers me all day I feel like
I'm like a like a young Larry David
which is like you know I know it shows
jokes and all that but it's obviously
part of how he is like if this is this
has got to stop okay if you're at one of
my favorite place to eat is any place
where you could go to the counter and
order and then go sit down and they
bring you the food [__] these waiters
and waitresses [__] when you're at a
table and you got to do from an iPad no
I want a person at the counter I want to
walk up to that guy from the counter I
want to say I want a coffee and a bagel
or a [__] breakfast burrito then I
want to go sit down
I want to take your stupid square gross
plaqued
[__] disease-infested number 35 walk
it over to my table put it in the little
[__] holder and wait for my thing
that's what I want don't give me a cute
ass waitress or waiter that's what I
want but here's the
[__] rule if you're with a group one
person orders and pays one person pays
if you want to figure it out later
who owes who what do that but you don't
walk up with a group of six and each pay
for your own [__] it takes too long and
there's a line [__] heads I gotta wait
an extra 10 minutes to get my [__]
chicken because these [__]
[__] ass okay this and that and it
would here's the other thing
the menus been there since you've been
in line read it before you get up there
oh can i this oh my ex was the worst
dude what do you recommend what do you
recommend you're in your 30s you know
what the [__] tastes like every place
has [__] chicken or salad or [__]
beef and they got an Italian dressing
oil and vinegar and some [__] hot
sauce that's what every place has you
got the nerve to walk up to a counter
and say what do you recommend now that's
okay to do when there's no line but when
there's a line you deserve to get a
[__] toe cut off I'm the toe
collector when it comes to that oh
excuse me just collecting toes
everyone's [__] up the line I'm just
collecting toes
come on dude
yeah like I set with the program dude
come on man
and we're worried about hurting people's
feelings
what about wasting their [__] time
dude that's the thing that matters way
more than people's feelings [__] your
feelings dude [__] your feelings respect
my time how [__] is this goddamn thing
work
I hate this [__] thing okay there we
go alright cut didn't do [__] oh this is
it
I just unbelievable with it with it with
the line [__] I go to this place the
line curves around and [__] and then
people take it upon themselves to be
like oh this is where the lines gonna go
now will will curve it around this way
and it's like in the way of a [__]
fire zone and I go as [__] a fire
you're gonna fire it's a fire and I got
ya but this is where the line was and
everyone's burning alive now I don't
know I don't know anymore
you know what I think's a myth or at
least it's never happened to me blue
balls yeah but what there's a pain in
your balls or something
guys swear by that off girl teases you
then all the pressure builds up in the
[__] huh you're not a wind tunnel I
don't get blue balls period I can hold
it forever no pressure no nothing never
have I ever gotten blue balls you have
yeah ever
I haven't get rid of never got blue
balls what is it it's like an ache it
was really bad yeah I know I know what
it is one far as like it's like if you
never get to come oh really
[Laughter]
no yeah no I mean I've I've I've been
you know horny or whatever plenty of
times and kissing and not had the thing
happened and it [__] never hurt ever
in my life
after that I go like this oh well and I
walk away and it doesn't hurt my balls
and it doesn't hurt anything
in fact I walk we gotta we gotta get it
but dude you should have seen the
[__] I tried to get them to do a
sound board oh my god
it was [__] to you be like here look
the sound board and one fire would be
like click it and twenty seconds later
it would be like Danny I don't think
done and think Donnie any taunting we're
gonna get it though and it's gonna be
lit dude it's gonna be [__] lit we're
gonna have hit him up on there it's
gonna be awesome I'm ready for it
what's that song gonna be a bright
bright bright bright sunshiny day what's
that song I
that's what I do when a girl doesn't let
me give him rain is gone what the [__]
is it called it's not though I can see
what I mean knows it oh oh my library
and I'm mad when you're in my library
and and you're like where is it I I
tuned iTunes doesn't have anything go Oh
Apple music dude that's why do I like
now I don't think I'm ready to do this
and then I I'm sitting there with a
[__] heart without with a horizontal
sausage and [__] okay well catch you
later then walk it down the duck could
still see clearly dude doesn't matter
never had blue balls doesn't matter okay
stop the mr. right right with the blue
boss walking out I'll explode later off
to get a [__] breakfast burrito up
there's a line pay for it all together
hey there they are they're paying all
together
alright [__] yeah ha ha got that burrito
quick young just tweet something send it
look at that a bunch of recruits and
nobody's feelings are hurt nice let me
check my email
Hey look at that an offer to go play
Emerson University any stipulations no
they're offering me that much
Oh Oh
nice Hey look at that
let me check Instagram what's up [__] DJ
Khaled is not being unbelievably
annoying whoa hey what the [__] a chick
is posting a picture of her tits and not
pretending it's about a watch or coffee
scrub what the [__]
guess I gotta keep on moving like what a
beautiful day Hey look at that nice car
what the [__] why are the windows rolled
down and then you and then you get
shocked cuz days like that don't happen
you get shot and then you're choking on
your own blood and you're [__] and
and people are like oh Danny I got in
there somebody's trying to take a
[__] video of it on snapchat and
they're like oh [__] dude and the last
thing you hear is like [__] and then
you hear a car drive by and it's playing
and it's playing this [__] and you're
like this is the last song I get to hear
and you're like oh my god that sucks and
then you die and the last thing I heard
is a Nelly song those are the last thing
you heard in life was a Nelly song
imagine it was this one
are you imagine getting imagine this
songs on and you got [__] like
imagine the songs on it at a bar and you
go to the bathroom and someone beats the
living [__] out of you
to a bloody pulp and you're dying and
they leave and you're dying and this
song playing and you're just like are
you barely with it then you're just like
oh [__] I wanna die
please somebody come in but you're like
a can't move it hurts too much and then
you just pass away listening to Kelly
Rowland Zanelli
my boo you know God what if that's the
last word you heard my boo basic basic
basic basic basic mmm but it can do this
and anybody can do this
hi Anne
dude that's so funny that song rock when
this came out no blue balls complete
explosion Oh
dumpin Oh what the [__] you in a oh my
god that was that was that the first a
of all time first of all hot easy first
of all I said so hot and listen dude and
then the girl goes ah dude oh wow
[Music]
so hot and then was just dude Nelly
one time I've [__] whatever one time
there was a guy in in in high school in
one fires high school and he told me
that he would he would go like sell
drugs and he caught he's like sometimes
I just go to Santa Barbara and dump and
he was talking about selling drugs he
called it dumping it's like dude she's
so awesome to go to Santa Barbara and
just dump oh man so high in oh [__] I
love it I love it
dump in you know what else can we talk
about before we I'm feeling I'm still
feeling pretty good I still have this
note that I had I have like three notes
today and one of them was host horrible
and I don't know what the [__] that
means I think was that was it there must
have been a while ago I just love what I
said hosting something would be the most
horrible job in the world worse than
crack [__] but Nelly I met him the
other day he's every time I think of
Nelly I think of a guy who once said to
me I was getting a Tupac thing framed
and I brought up Tupac I couldn't get
through it couldn't get through the
podcast without breaking up Tupac
unbelievable I was getting a thick frame
that guy said oh you like Tupac I said
yeah he said yeah he's one of my
favorites I said oh yeah he said yeah
he's like who else do you like I was I
got a knock didn't no one talked to the
guy I was like he was a gay man I love
Tupac and I also think Nell he's pretty
real that's what he said
Nellie's pretty real so funny dude
not that he's not real but like just the
wording and like I yeah I love Tupac and
also I think Nellie's pretty real the
bandaid on his cheek superfluous the
band-aid
cheek what if the whole time we didn't
know but like he had to bend at his
cheek in the woman when he pulled it off
you had like a huge boil or a tattoo of
Nellie a tattoo of Nellie's face nobody
did that flirty thing with the [__]
12 year old or the 44 year old on the on
the on the he did like the weird like he
was singing the song to Nellie was
singing the song to the kid and he was
like flirting with her and she was like
hey Nellie there's the internet don't do
that someone's gonna video it and say
what are you doing Nellie serenades
another nervous little girl on stage a
gives her his glasses curls and twirls
her hair so close so weird
whatever though I mean it's not like
[Music]
that's good
III guess we're done I mean I get we can
take some twittered you have any good
ones except you guys I all I do is come
up with a new thing and say like ah it's
not a new thing by the way it's been
around my [__] life forever except
calling something so [__] but like so
many people are [__] it to this how
[__] is that you're [__] almost all
wrong
how [__] is it to sign something Gilly
what this is cool Victoria writes made
them grad cap and ode to Daddy even
though of course [__] ceremonies and she
put me on there that's cool [__]
ceremonies but still made it about the
cult Victoria underscore underscore
Barra that's cool hey soos Miguel choppa
Jay underscore underscore choppa how
much of your shows specials are
improvised um I don't know how to answer
that question maybe 10% I mean the the
podcast is completely the park is
completely improvised but the the shows
or specials like on stage I mean it
depends
but you know specials or come out to be
I don't know my incorrigible some of the
stuff was improvised
um and then even some of the stuff know
my last special none of it was really
improvised I don't think except for the
and when it come when I the thing after
the card that comes up because
afterwards because the mic went out I
was just [__] around the first it's
just like odd moments here and there
it's not not crazy improvised
I mean sometimes when I'm on stage and
not shooting I'll do [__] I'll just make
[__] up but for the specials that's like
the worked on material usually easy H
King ill music I want to know what Chris
Thalia thinks of that Pusha T album yeah
I liked it a lot dude I liked it a lot I
liked it a lot
but but dude I've been on the push at t
train I'm not gonna be one of those
annoying guys that's like I liked him
since before you guys were just [__] I
hate that [__]
but yeah I've liked him forever I've
I've I've constantly I've said he's the
best rapper he's definitely one of the
rappers alive I saw him once at a diner
and I was like and he made eye contact I
was like oh what's up and he was like
what's up Chris and it was like made my
[__] week and told him I was a big
fan and then he didn't say it back so
that's cool um so ya know it was great
it was great it's a great album and then
people are making like all but the disc
that the Drake disc is even better no
it's not Drake I like Drake
I like Drake's music and that this
wasn't bad but like come on that [__]
push it the album was like the hottest
[__] all year anyway yeah the Pusha T
albums [__] awesome you gotta listen
to it alright I'm gonna I'm out I'm done
okay yeah we're good blue apron check
out this week's menu and get your first
three mills free at blue apron calm /
Congrats square cash get check out the
new boost rewards program get the cash
app and two rewards code Congrats
get five dollars and give five dollars -
times up get it for iOS or Android now
go to the Chris
Leigha calm for all the dates coming up
I got a lot of East Coast stuff going
for the follow the follow the leader
tour Chris Thalia calm please subscribe
to the YouTube channel check out the
YouTube videos that go up every Tuesdays
or Wednesdays down download the Chris
D'Elia app for iOS and Android or
Android please
all the [__] helps man it really does
subscribe rate and review the show tweet
on iTunes or whatever you can do that it
really helps watch my specials Lonnie on
on Netflix and Comedy Central and thank
you for listening you guys you guys are
the best
spread the word
[Music]